and by the way when you have you had a
job have you been employed let's say not
like kind of like college-age but like
since then or have you just done
businesses of your own we had like an
acquisition and I was kind of employed
there but I but you haven't gone and
just interviewed for jobs
I interviewed once a couple times and I
never got them what you interview for
for fungal for Jack Smith my best friend
I and I didn't get it they just didn't
call me back tell you the guy who's like
my best friend now I didn't know him I
interviewed his job oh you didn't know
him at the time
I didn't know okay me and they didn't
hire me and then two years later became
best friends and you were trying to be a
salesperson or what I don't remember I
think so
by the way I have a similar story I
applied to stripe I think I might have
told the story already so apology if I
did but 2012 I applied to I I was gonna
apply for a job for the first time in my
life I'd started two companies before
that I was like I'm moving to Silicon
Valley I'm gonna get a job I'm gonna
learn from other people rather than
start my own thing
and I only applied to jobs
one was stripe and I got to the phone
screen and I really had it made because
the guy who was interviewing me his
mentor in life was one of my former
advisors in my startup and had written a
blog post being like this guy Sean he's
like he said it specifically he has the
highest bias for action of any
entrepreneur I've ever met he made a
warm intro to this guy and was like
trust me this guy's legit you should
hire this kid [__] did you not get that
job and so I I thought I was cruising
too and maybe that's why I didn't get it
but I get to the part of the interview
where he was like alright you know this
job has a lot of sort of sales and
persuasion stuff so you know we're peace
software so I want you to you know we're
gonna do a little roleplay you're gonna
sell me a piece of software and he's
like you could pick any software you
like whatever you're familiar with you
probably got creative or something and I
was just like um I was like okay so I
here's what I would do I would talk to
you about this he said no no don't tell
me what you would do like I'm the
customer hello I just picked up the
phone go and I was like [__] and so I I
was like hey you know I'm telling you
about
I picked Basecamp as my software big
mistake because I don't even know
Basecamp very well so I just like pull I
just say they didn't call you back for
that reason
by the by the end of that roleplay he
was just like yeah I don't think this is
for you I'm just being honest with you
like I just don't think you're you know
I'm good for this that was eight years
ago
some yeah I was like probably 2023 year
24 at the time how [__] however but I'm
like I I blew it like it wasn't there
bad like I definitely blew that
interview how early of an employee would
you have been so I think they were at
like 50 maybe 50 people or less or a
hundred people I see five million
dollars well yeah I don't know how much
equity I would have had to do the rocket
ship thing I would have had to start in
the crappy seat crush it and then get
into a good seat to get equity but like
I did that with uber and airbnb I had
job interviews at Airbnb and uber first
100 people and one of them I got and one
of them I got the offer but then they
rescinded it cuz I lied about my resume
and the other one I didn't get past I
had a criminal record and I told my
didn't oh alright don't come to work on
Monday dude that's hilarious
at least you had good eye for picking
these companies and then I applied at
bungle and they sold for 800 million
dollars so I always tell people find out
where I want to work at who will also
deny me and then invest there okay let's
start with where would you want to work
at today if you were you back then where
would you be applying today great
question
do you have an answer you want to go for
a couple years ago I answer this I was
like the only place I would be really
interested working with his angel list
at the time no I'd be horrible at a
place to work and so I thought Angelus
was doing really interesting [__] and I
think it's gonna be big and it did end
up becoming big and this was like seven
years ago this is a while ago ya know
that would be a horrible place to work
though because that wall guy was [__]
crazy really I don't know he seems like
a brilliant genius so a great - but a
horrible person to manage you if okay if
I had to work somewhere I probably hmm
probably just somewhere with really good
managers most startups have horrible
managers and when you were looking at
uber Airbnb you didn't know the managers
so you weren't using that criteria vent
no but and I don't know if it would been
successful Sara my wife works at Airbnb
and she loves her managers and
you know how everyone's like so what are
you gonna do next they always say that
and she's like what do you mean by
whatever do anything next is awesome
would be for a really long time right
and I would love to have that feeling
I would probably now look for a company
that's I would go find all the most
interesting biotech based companies so
anybody doing something with genetics
genomics modification anything like that
I think that's a big wave that's coming
I do try to be early they're
self-driving cars if there's someone
who's awesome there I do something in
that if it's hard though it's really
hard if I wanted to make a lot of money
let's say I wanted to like Akari I'm
gonna try and save hundreds of thousands
of dollars in the next three years of
work good work a face book or what well
Facebook Google or an enterprise sales
role at a super boring b2b meet
enterprise software company right where
the where the average deal is like three
or four hundred thousand dollars a year
right that's what I would so if I took
my own advice I would look for who's a
rocket ship so I would try to maybe like
lambda school I think it's interesting I
would just basically try to go find
who's the fastest growing startup right
now that's at maybe 50 people or 20
people or what are the ten people
whatever they are I would go try to find
them and then I would be like hey I'll
come solve any problems you got like
we'll figure it out I went to the sub
stack office the other day they just
raised 16 million dollars and funding
you know how many employees they have
five five I would that would be an
interesting place to work
[Music]
you